Bonsoir les jeunes.
Et bonsoir les... les vieux.
Le problème avec le sida, c'est que quand t'as un pote qui l'a,
bah, après il meurt.. et ça, c'est chiant.
La blague qui installe le malaise !
Et ouais, le sida ça installe le malaise.
On peux pas trop rigoler avec ce genre de sujet, parce que... c'est juste hyper grave.
Par contre, ensemble, on peut lutter contre.
C'est très simple.
Alors, soit tu trouves un vaccin contre le sida.
Mais ça demande beaucoup d'années d'études.
Ou alors, vraiment plus simple, en 10 secondes, t’utilise ça.
C'est une capote.
XXL
Mais bon, celle-là, c'est à un pote.
Alors je vais pas vous faire une démo, mais c'est super simple.
C'est un préservatif que tu mets sur ton sexe.
Et ça évite pas mal de problèmes,
comme par exemple les enfants.
Allez, la blague nulle !!
On rigole, bien sûr. C'est vraiment bien la vie.
Donc vous voyez, c'est pas si compliqué de lutter contre le sida.
Il suffit d'avoir ça en permanence sur soi.
Moi, celle-là, je l'ai sur moi depuis 4 ans.
Ah, pas parce que j'ai fait l'amour sans capote, hein ?
Non, non. Juste parce que j'ai... j'ai pas fait l'amour.
Mettez des capotes. Au moins une.
Ça marche aussi avec une.
Bon, c'est dégueu, hein.
Mais quand t'es dedans, c'est sympa.
Moi j'avais essayé une fois, et...
...et j'ai des bons souvenirs.
Donc mon message, il est vraiment tout simple.
Certains pourrait le trouver même banal, mais c'est jamais trop de le rappeler.
Mettez des préservatifs !
Et faites l'amour. Faites beaucoup l'amour, c'est hyper important.
Et soutenez le Sidaction !
Allez. Ciao.